when I was 25 years old I was diagnosed
with Hodgkin's disease and ended up
facing a year of chemotherapy and
radiation treatments and as strange is
this going to sound and I often tell
this to my mother sometimes the worst
things that happen to you have a silver
lining and often in many respects they
end up being the best things that
happened to you I know it's hard for
that to believe it she's never willing
to take that but it changed the course
of my life and the reason it did was
because my parents raised the four of us
my my siblings in a very risk inverse
very traditional environment and I saw
my career in a very lock step ladder way
after that happened I looked at myself
much more in my career in my personal
life much more with a real sense of
urgency I'd been faced at a very young
age with a doctor telling me who knows
how much longer how much time you really
have in fact by a fifty percent chance
that you won't make it to 30 that's a
pretty sobering statement to receive at
that age and I took that as really a
call to action and I did many things
personally and professionally at that
point that probably most people don't
have the benefit of doing at 25 years
old I will say I became less patient and
perhaps that's not a virtue but I think
in your career many people and i'll be
honest i think a lot of women tend to
sit back and see what's going to happen
to their career I think you need to
recognize that to really move forward
you need to take an active role in
managing your career even from a very
young age so for me it's always sort of
making sure somewhere in there you have
a bit more sense of urgency than perhaps
you would normally have about making
sure you're moving yourself along and I
got that by having a you know going
through a very challenging personal
event in my life that forced me to feel
like I needed to have a sense of urgency
but I think a healthy sense of urgency
and willingness to take some risks and
push yourself outside of your comfort
generally speaking rarely has its
downsides and I think most organizations
today are looking for people willing to
take more risk and are a bit more
tolerant of failure than they used to be
you know keep that in mind and keep that
sense of urgency in order to sort of
continue to propel your career I think
that's the best advice I could give
anybody at a young age